Drake's star-studded new video Beyonce
and jay-z on the run from thunderstorms
Plus Kylie Jenner is vibing her man
Travis Scott's new album hey kids this
is the daily Denny but more importantly
its new music Friday will have the hot
tracks that I'm filling this week for
you in just a few but first
speaking of Drake is in my feelings and
stuck in my head the star-studded visual
for in my feelings is all about you
guessed it
but in my feelings challenge which to be
fair not only did it help make this song
a number one single for Drizzy but he
didn't even have to choreograph it the
video starring Felicia Rashad and La La
Anthony dropped last night with other
stark cameos from Will Smith and Ryan
Seacrest to do a Lipa drake pays tribute
to those who helped make his single a
number one hit with their viral Shiggy
challenge videos all right he did
include my challenge video but that's
all right Drake I forgive you you know
who isn't it though comedian shaggy who
started the whole thing he also pops up
and I love that it's shot in New Orleans
though I'm gonna say we need some more
Big Freedia in this you feel me anyway
the woman behind the video also directed
Drake's God's plan and nice for what
videos this tribute also shows fans
ghost riding with the you know moving
car stunts gone wrong the dangerous
fails aren't on there these are from the
internet and I'm not gonna lie I get a
kick out of them too but this these
challenge mishaps got officials posting
warnings that's right this oklahoma road
sign blares Kiki stay in your car and
the NTSB posted this advice don't jump
out of a moving car for a mean so cheeky
responsibly kids while y'all are running
out your cars last night Beyonce and
jay-z fans were on the run from
thunderstorms the crowd at the Carters
concert was temporarily evacuated from
the stands and New Jersey's MetLife
Stadium and after an hour delay B and
jay-z continued into the wee hours now
the reward for the patient crowd a
little PDA from mom and dad and a
special shout-out from the Queen herself
so much for a beautiful night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Carter's on the run to tour picks right
back up tonight at MetLife and they'll
be in LA next month and I've said it
before I cannot wait until then let's
celebrate another Beyonce classic baby
boy featuring Sean Paul turns 15 today
and our Deidre Behar recently caught up
with Sean Paul about his memories
working with be on the track I don't
know if you guys know this this summer
is the 15 year anniversary of baby boy
Wow that's a minute how does that feel
does it feel like it was 15 years ago
many feels like I know time was taught
to me like I just went truly an iconic
song that we are still dancing to today
talk to me about working with Beyonce in
that experience and what you maybe have
as your favorite memory oh it's just her
her focus you know when you're around
her and she's working which is what it
was it was just amazing focus and you
saw that she had this plan for forever
but she wasn't gonna let little problems
kind of get in the way she was going
with the flow also we're very
professional that's what I got from her
amazing sounds I was glad to be on it I
was bad at she wanted to do dance or
music and yeah by the way we were with
Sean at this set of his music video with
Becky gee that's why she's in it but
Beyonce's been performing remixes a baby
boy at her show so it lives on people
but it is time to highlight some new
tracks for our new music Friday playlist
Travis Scott just dropped his latest
album Astroworld
he and baby mama Kylie Jenner celebrated
the drop in Chicago last night where
they packed on some PDA Kylie called his
latest album the craziest ride in my
life and I could tell but she's also not
wrong
Travis's song stargazing got me jam and
[Music]
there are so many collaborators on
Astroworld so take a listen let us know
what you guys paint speaking of
collaborations Camila Kibeho teamed up
with bazi for a new duet of his track
beautiful and it's good
[Music]
Camila took that song to the next level
am i right
and finally Robin is back and better
than ever if you love call your
girlfriend and dancing on my own
the singer returns to form with her
latest missing you
[Music]
you guys couldn't tell but I was dancing
to that like just by myself well that
was playing all right there you have it
the jam to kickstart your week and right
let us know what you guys are listening
to and I'll see you on Monday with
another dose of the daily dedi bye guys
[Music]